a new way of talking about the drug
problem would be let's talk about drugs
in terms of what they do what do we want
and what do they do so here you have a
family of drugs and and the typical
image of the addict what is a drug
addict well it's a person who has an
obsessive behavior pattern that is
unexamined and that causes them to
return again and again to the same
source of stimulus or the same source of
stimulus without ever cognizing the
reason why in other words unexamined
behavior is what is alarming about drug
addiction the people behave like they
are obsessed well on that scale then the
most powerful drug of the late 20th
century is television and propaganda and
the way in which we consume propaganda
is amazing I mean the most intelligent
of us the ones who hold ourselves most
aloof are probably junkies through and
through when it comes to the media and
the media just makes you stupider and
stupider and stupider you become less
able to formulate a creative response
less able to tell what is real and what
is not less able to empower yourself and
this is more and more and more of it the
average American watches six and a half
hours of TV per day average imagine if a
drug that you smoked or shoot or snort
had been introduced into this country
after World War two and that now the
average American was consuming six and a
half hours a day of this thing I mean
you would have the fundamentalist
foaming at the mouth there would be
riots in the street it's that we define
these things so oddly we don't attempt
to make sense what I was trying to say
this morning about the fact that we must
change our mind
we must change our minds business as
usual will lead to exacerbated conflict
over resources and turf and eventually
thermal nuclear catastrophe if the
evolution of consciousness is not the
way to solve the world's problems then I
don't know what it is
well the psychedelics were originally
described as consciousness expanding
drugs that was the phenomenological
description of what they were we need to
intervene in our own psyches we cannot
afford the luxury of an unconscious mind
that can throw up a Hitler or home
mainly we cannot afford the unexamined
obsessive behavior pattern that leads us
into a conditioned response when
somebody leans on our territory or
insults our racial heritage or something
like that we have to realize that it is
going to take creative intellectual
engineering to steer us through the the
narrow valley of being and it's always
been that way this is what shamanism is
is using plants to balance and control
what is otherwise an extremely
violence-prone neurotic species the
price we pay when the symbiotic
relationship to the rest of nature is
interrupted we lose our bearings I'm not
talking metaphorically I don't mean
about sniffing the air and making
medicine wheels I mean about putting the
the chemicals the enzymes from the
natural environment into your body that
create the seamless web that unites us
to the purpose of the planet
these psychedelic compounds are bearing
information they are pheromones from the
body of Gaia that we by imbibing can
then attune ourselves to the larger
purposes of nature so that we then can
fit ourselves into the picture we have a
purpose it is it is to care for the
planet to nurture it and lead it forward
much the way bees do much the way
termites do but we are conscious
creatures are carrying our honey making
our act architectonic activities operate
on a different epistemic mode because we
are somehow one foot in a higher
dimension this is the mystery of our
selves
[Music]